my name is Samuel Leeds I'm a property
investor I've trained thousands and
thousands of property investors and one
of the things people ask me is Samuel
what's your biggest challenge what's the
hardest thing about property investing
why the most property investors fail
well I'm gonna give you in that in this
video the six reasons as to why most
property investors fail find out these
reasons and make sure you're not one of
them don't forget to smash that like
button also subscribe if you're not
already subscribed hit that notification
bow learn the reasons do the maths make
the money number one people fail because
they spend too much time doing
spreadsheets and not enough time viewing
houses the person that makes the most
money is always the person that makes
the most viewings and puts in the most
offers forward I see so many amateur
landlords messing around with
spreadsheets working out the return on
investment before they even view in the
house like there was one guy he spent an
hour and a half working out the all the
spreadsheet all the details on a house
and the house didn't exist it was
actually located in Barcelona wrongly
listed in Birmingham he's crunching the
numbers and doing the research on the
house that's in another friggin country
but that sounds stupid some people are
because and the reason people do that is
because working on a spreadsheet is an
excuse as to why they're not going to do
in houses speaking to people put in an
office so my advice to you would be if
you want to fail then go ahead and do
your spreadsheets if you want to succeed
you've got to get in front of people
you've got a few houses spreadsheets
come later not the other way around
number two is this most people by the
traditional way and they'll always fail
doing this the traditional way is to
save up a deposit put that down on a
house save up for another deposit put
that down on another house that is going
to take to you so many years probably
decades in order to build off a property
portfolio that's actually giving you a
life-changing amount of money you do not
need to buy the traditional way you want
to use creative strategies such as joint
ventures raising finance lease options
venture rents is okay but but these are
the strategies you need to
it's just a case of people buying in the
traditional way because they do not
realize that you there is no other way
that's how they fail number three I've
struggled in this area and a lot of
deals fall through a lot of people fail
a lot of people quit because of a bad
power team if your mortgage broker is
not having conversations with your
solicitor and this solicitor is not
having conversations with the estate
agent and that your power team aren't
communicating with one another and
you're the only point of contact you're
going to really struggle because you're
going to be constantly chasing you're
going to be constantly being chased and
your team they're not on a mission
they're not working together they're
just all over the place a bad power to a
bad power team is gonna mean bad failure
is coming your way so make sure you've
got a good team that have been referred
to you make sure that your team talks or
one another make sure you've got a good
team that's really really important
number four I see many investors failing
because of this
don't be a skinflint people say watch
the pennies and the pounds will look
after themselves I say you get too
wrapped up in focusing on the pennies
you'll lose the pounds I'll give you an
example of this if something needs
fixing in one of your rental properties
and you think I'm gonna hold off fixing
it what will happen is you ten it will
move out and then you've lost the pounds
what happened is that little leak that
you were thinking are maybe we'll just
fix itself miraculously I don't want to
spend a hundred pound getting it fixed
up that lowly twill become a big leak
there's something you need a new carpet
as well don't be a skinflint just fix
things if a group of tenants come up to
you say hey you've just had a brand new
HMO come to the market you got five
rooms available me and my four friends
want to move in but we want it we want a
little discount can you give us can you
can you not ten pound off each month for
us and you're like no ten pound each
month how many McDonald's could I buy
for that and then you gotta wait longer
to fill the rooms because you were
greedy
I don't be a skinflint don't obsess over
the pennies look at the bigger picture
the cabbage depreciation of the house
and honestly curtain corners when you're
getting a job don't just get a job done
properly don't use a cowboy plumber to
fix your toilet because it's 20 pounds
so just use a proper plumber and get a
guarantee with that and don't be a
skinflint I seen people losing money all
the time
I've been sick influence number five I
think this is really what it comes down
to this is the biggest the biggest
reason why people fail and that is just
a lack of belief a lack of belief and
the lack of education I think it was
Henry Ford who said if you believe you
can or if you believe you can't you're
right I think one of the reasons I was
so successful when I was seventeen is
because I was naive and just believed
what my trainers were telling me I was
just like okay it's possible and I just
followed and believed in the system
people these days often they're so
cynical they're so skeptical and there's
they they don't believe in the system
and they also don't believe in
themselves you're going to manifest what
you believe that's just obvious massive
problem in property investing property
investing is one of the most lucrative
professions on the planet if you look at
the summer Times Rich List guess what
they all buy houses they're all invest
in property pretty much but people think
to become a doctor you got to go to
university and study for four or five
years and spend a hundred grand becoming
a doctor but to become a professional
property investor and make tens of
millions of pounds over over your
profession you don't want to spend
twelve pound buying a book it's just
madness lack of belief lack of training
being a skinflint having a bad Power
Team buying traditionally not being
creative doing too many spreadsheets
rather than just going out there and
viewing houses and putting offers
forward there's are five reasons what
most people fail if you want to be
successful if you don't want to be like
most investors and most people that fail
which most people do if you want to be a
successful investor want to succeed I'd
recommend that you come down to the
property investors crash course and
guess what it's free so link below
tickets on me on the house get your
tickets quick because they're always
going to sell out and I'll look forward
to seeing you at the property investors
crash course also please don't forget to
smash that like button and subscribe and
drop a comment below thanks so much I'll
see you next time
[Music]